you
hi everyone is Jerry I'm on HS org right
now and I'm playing a 15-2 game so let's
see how this plays out it's been a while
since I played a standard game usually
bulletin blitz but it's nice to be able
to stop and actually think so let's see
what we have in this one mm-hmm
King side to being keto six one of those
two something else
NYX okay go with Knight f3 one see if
Bishop b4 is on board I'm fine with
trading dark square bishop so kai we
don't have that and tray uh but no any
structure so let's grab some space with
d5 okay so not an immediate capture not
sure if there's a great difference
usually its first takes and then
recapture so my night belongs here 9c3
and i could think about efore okay
that's a little bit awkward hmm east six
and then a couple moves later e5 hmm
some time is lost there but with the
closed position I don't know that that
will be such a great factor I'm pretty
sure I know where my epon belongs
sometimes they'll be this maneuver but
in this case with the pawn on c4 so I
don't think there's a reason not to play
e4 here yeah they might that might play
Bishop g4 and eliminate their Bishop for
my knight sensible with a
position with black having less space
okay
don't have that my approach will be with
this pond furthest to this furthest
advanced pawn on d5 this Queen side pawn
this is where I have a space advantage
so I'll be looking for this idea but the
question is when probably only after I
have only after I have some more
development in now where might this
night be going hmm
I think black might pivot on f8 prior to
castling and then jump into g6 I might
have to start I might need to be
concerned with Knight f4 stuff I could
play g3 but I'm weakening my light
squares let's see can I do without
castling here probably not I have to get
castling in so if they're gonna go for
night to f8 I can't stop them
I could I could consider this maneuver
it's probably uh it's probably a good
one yeah I should go in for that I'd
much rather have my knight responsible
for defending f4 then upon and now this
this Knight here will be really well
placed on d3 it's probably the best
piece that I have a knight on d3 so
let's get there follow through notice it
facilitates both pawn breaks f4 in b4 so
super strong piece here on d3 now I
wonder I could definitely play a 3 and B
4 here and that's one plan and the other
is f4 although I need to be concerned
with the e5 square being given up
no I would really if I could get my pawn
to f5 I think that would be probably a
win it just controls the whole board
there'd be too little space for black to
work with so if I play g3 well for one
at weekends age three there's Bishop h3
with tempo but this idea of g3 and f4
takes I recapture at the pun and I'm
securing the five square but maybe I
don't need to go in that direction at
all if I make nothing moves I think
blacks forward blacks progress is in the
form of f5 so I'm moving the Knight to
d7 and then playing f5 or maybe this
square so that the bishop observes f5
but getting the knight out of the way
and playing f5 is probably blacks idea I
wonder I could always try for first a 3
and B 4 see if black plays a 5 just to
stop b4 for just a little bit at least
on a3 a5 I'll have the B 5 square for my
knight at some stage I'm just wondering
if I should be going for g3 and f4
um I don't know no no no I'm not gonna
do that I just noticed something and
that is if they play this if they move
this night I have Bishop g4 offering a
light square bishop exchange exchanging
my bad bishop for their good Bishop and
even if they get the f5 move in I take
and then I'll have this nice post for my
knight on e4 one thing have to be
concerned about without this pawn on e4
it allows a knight to maybe one day
pivot on f5 and once he's there he is
getting into d4 and that's a vet would
be a very difficult piece to work around
okay
so two things are happening Black's
preventing B for at least for the moment
but is giving up the b5 square something
I may want to jump into at some stage
could play rugby
the first thought that comes to mind
here I don't hold on
I sure what exactly I'm accomplishing by
playing rook B 1 and B 4 because at the
end they played B 6 I don't like giving
this rook activity home moves to
consider here I'm thinking about Bishop
to e3 and yeah let's do that
because it's a developing move so just
one move away from being fully developed
I have to be a little bit concerned
about a move like this in fact maybe I'm
overlooking that come to think of it
because my knight is restricted a form
might be a move here yeah so I think I
this was a misstep Bishop e3 but we'll
see what the engine have to has to say
after this so I have to be concerned
about this positional idea of a for
right now clamping down in this
structure let's start out with b3 yeah I
think a4 was a move we'll see what the
we'll see if it's being suggested we'll
see where there's some evaluation shifts
after this game so they really trying to
play b5 I wouldn't mind seeing that
let's start with Brooke b1 just to be in
a position to break my rook
might be able to get to the seventh rank
with some good effect good influence in
the position so is this night ever going
to move when I try something like h6
night h7 to get in at five but I'm fine
with Adam I'm prepared okay they are
going for this I think it's a mistake
I'm almost certain it's a mistake
because I have discovered stuff at the
end hitting the queen and a winning
material and I'll have the bishop pair
so I think that this was a
miscalculation here by black my bishop I
need to yeah they're going right into
this discovered attack so just
questioning the move order here just
questioning if something is better than
to first take the bishop and then move
the knight taking this pawn I don't
think so well actually I could take
either pond but um it's actually no well
if I take here the Queen gets out of the
way my knight is attacked and it has to
move and then I would drop efore so I
want to be able to take take another
piece and then secure my e4 pawn I have
to be a little bit concerned about my
darks the dark squares though if I take
on e5 sure I'm winning upon and then I
take this tonight they recapture this
pawn is hit I have to there is some
concern I have for Knight d7 Bishop to
f6 and blacks minor pieces pivoting on
this newly open square on e5 although
we do something else taking on this
square and then playing knight c6 not
quite sure um the question right now is
which pawn to take I'm still looking at
this it seems it seems correct you know
let's go with that take on e5 it's a
central pawn and maybe I could look into
putting now my central majority now that
it's two-to-one majority in the center
try to put that into use and I want to
get the move back so let's just take
this piece and then and then think about
opening the position in fact okay I
wasn't expecting that taking away from
the center it does open up this F file
but the downside is that it weakens e6
hmm I'd really like to get my
into yz6 my first thought is after three
but I could forget about getting my
bishop into e6
I still want to have this move in mind
of Bishop g4 for when the knight moves
and I'm expecting it to move soon let's
start with Queen c2 to defend this
square we're staying off of d3 because
it runs in two tempos with the ninety
five and on a knight move Bishop g4 into
here I don't know how annoying it is I
think black can work around it on the
dark squares but okay I think that's a
good move let's start first with f3 I
guess I have to give up this idea of
playing a Bishop to g4 on a knight move
oh I missed that move but actually they
missed a pin that's uh I should have I
should have considered that the bishops
weakened he's unprotected but this is
now running into this pin I didn't see
that my opponent didn't see it either
but this is game over now that's pin
he's head twice he can't be defended
I'll probably resign here this whole
whole farm is following this is a full
piece maybe even then some broke in the
corner you know I'll be curious to see
what the computer has to say after this
but let's see what black does next
plenty of time here six minutes
still the two second increment ah let's
see
so now
can do maybe rook here or King here in
situations like this well it's
completely losing for black but you know
in in more closely fought positions like
this I'd be going with the king move
prior instead of a rook move he's gonna
he's going to have to play to h8 once
he's in check so make the move with the
piece that has the least amount of
flexibility first it's the king so King
h8 Bishop takes Knight again it's
completely winning for white but at
least there's some flexibility with the
rook he could do some he has more
options than the King would so let's see
what black does they've been in it for
maybe about a minute now let's see try
to do
more standard games this is actually my
very first rated game unli chess with
the standard time control they're gonna
let their time tick I wonder okay no
they're not letting their time tick what
I was just thinking about there is that
if they were going to let their time
tick eyes to some editing and save you
the time from watching just the black
clock tick away so no reason not to just
take the night right I don't have to
actually he's not going anywhere
so let's get to let's get another piece
involved I'm I don't need to go in for
the b4 move let's just pile up on that
pin tonight it may be better to
recapture with the rook and then double
my bishop is fine where he's out this is
also another again it's it's a winning
position for white but uh you know still
being as a technical and precise as
possible you know you could you could
take like this but I think it is better
to be taking like this now that they're
out of the pen let's take that night
this is a better improvement with the
rook take the piece and you're preparing
to double so how to defend d6 okay with
the Queen let's get the other piece
working and they still have a back rank
issues so let's see
I could take on this square maybe in
some cases getting back here there is
this break as well if they try flight
square g6 would be hit so now this is a
this is a pin I have the e5 move now
let's follow through with that and open
up the position welcome more exchanges
more possibilities for the the pieces
that I have out and about the extra
piece as well so rook takes pawn pawn
takes or even more adding more fuel to
this pawn I don't know that I would want
to do this even though it's a passed
pawn I'd much rather have pieces or
pawns exchanged okay don't want to drop
this Bishop so I could take on this c5
square for one or I could play Bishop to
f6 just getting out of the line of fire
getting off of the e-file Bishop f4 is
my first thought let's go with it
pawn takes
my bishop but I take here and then I'm
also on the bishop on d8 so this pawn is
hit a ton of times now it'll be
collapsing soon tough to recommend
anything for black I mean all things
were equal the material was equally like
you think about flight squares and stuff
like that the bishops opposite my king
but I don't see a way to allow this pawn
to move you know another thing there's
three pieces on this dog and also a4 and
Bishop here win some more material hmm
could probably go in for that in the end
I'd be up a full rook or well I was
thinking here
Queen d3 and Bishop to b5 but that runs
into c4 stuff let's keep it really
really simple I'm not gonna get I'm
gonna go in for the more direct stuff
rook takes pawn most forceful a4 is
certainly setting up a threat but I
could look to be much more direct give
direction to my opponent limit my
opponent's responses and now probably
push e six yeah let's go with e6 this is
a fan
plastic piece here it's the extra piece
securing that pond got now rook d7 Queen
c3 stuff and also bishop here bishop c7
there's rook d7 that'll be more material
so this sir this is going to be my idea
my tomb of idea get to the 7th and prove
my pieces once more
Queen c3 moving forward more and then
taking advantage of this pin against the
pond I don't think it could be defended
in C that move but it should be ok
Queen C 3 and on Bishop here I still
have this move so let's first start with
Queen C 3 let's not get into time
pressure either clean C 3 Bishop C 7
rook d7 I'm threatening mate on g7 now
and hitting the bishop on c7 will
probably resign here I'm thinking this
is this is too much look g8 crawling up
into a ball or maybe just allowing the
mate on g7 okay they resigned so let me
not even step away here let me go into
actually I have to step away for a
second and just get a computer analysis
let's see
there we go yeah I just had to hit that
button and could see it here it just
takes a moment it's analyzing the game
and there we go this gives you an idea
of the and if there were any shifts in
the game and such I think you should be
able to see that there yeah we'll have a
look a closer look maybe at around yeah
is when that e5 move was played notice
that was the I was pointing out some
time was lost east six and then a couple
moves later d5 there was a closed
position but nothing was really given up
throughout let's see what let's see what
it has to say here just going through on
the right hand side we'll see where
there were some inaccuracies it also
logs right here one inaccuracy mistake
zero blunders on my end and for my
opponent the same stats however the same
details so let's get to let's say move
14 yeah went okay so when b5 was played
that was just the miscalculation there
but you know what another thing I was
pointing out that I think this move was
a mistake
I wonder if after this move a four would
have been a move hmm because a knight
takes here there's Knight takes e4 and
this is a favorable exchange of pawns
for sure black gives up a rook pawn but
white gives up a central pawn yeah I
think I think I should have done
something different here I should have
been a bit more concerned about this a
form of maybe I should have played b3
here I think this is a way that I could
have improved b3 and then there isn't
this idea anymore and then Bishop to e3
this is a mmm I was ready to say a small
detail but I think I it's it's a it's a
very big detail because I don't have the
Queen side play I don't get that be for
advance in I no longer have that Queen
side plan that's a that's not good a4 I
think is a good move here but I played
Bishop III then b3 and I guess this is
already where black could think about
doing something else but it's difficult
to suggest because it's difficult to
suggest something because you know this
miss f5 I'm prepared to meet those moves
like if the knight place here I was
gonna think about this and let's say a5
is played immediately takes takes takes
and after rook takes I just have this
enormous square on e4 and if challenged
I could even consider this and we
remember where maybe one day playing a a
good versus bad Bishop type position so
White's still going to maintain
something here I never like never quite
got an active plan on board so it was
tough I mean I got the well I what would
I have done if let's let's say what
would I have done if b5 wasn't played
you know let's say that black doesn't go
in for this idea because it's a
blundering upon and so let's let's say
hmm let's say b6 is played here what
would I do
I think I would still follow through
with this idea or maybe maybe first this
making what one might call a
non-committal move first
not yet weakening my Kings side playing
rugby one being in a position
to play rook - before you know this dish
might be the direction of going I don't
know that I need to play on the Kings
side or weaken my Kings side with g3 and
f4 much rather play in the Queens I
don't need to play in the Kings side I
think I could just play in the Queen
side it's B for let's say h6 pretty
useful flight square Knight pivot takes
takes and if black is taking like this I
don't know maybe this is even a bit
premature to be honest rook here maybe
sacrifices and then taking on this
square I think black would be happy for
something like that because they're
pretty cramped here white having a nice
space advantage
rook here Queen here not saying it's
best in any way but at least strikes an
imbalance in the position Queen here and
maybe this pawn starts to roll and it's
a bit more lively it's an active
approach for the black side so sensing
this I should maybe be a bit more
cautious about this before break maybe I
could get some more useful moves in h3
might be one of them no you know I just
I just I don't know for certain maybe
rook to e1 and then this g3 and F for
whenever g3 is played I'm always a bit
concerned about an immediate Bishop h3
hitting my rook so maybe I have the time
for moving the rook to e1 first I'm not
sure what to suggest for black it's
tough to suggest something as soon as
the knight moves I'm looking at this I
don't know that it's best but it has
that ID in mind of playing on the light
squares but let's I don't know let's say
make a King move g3 and then f4 I think
it's important that black plays this
move otherwise they get squashed
allowing this f5 move well the knight is
in fact
at that point but let's say King h7 here
knight in the corner well that's bad on
its own and now we have these ideas
although that might be a bit tricky to
get in because of these dark squares
that are controlled with the Queen and
Bishop but uh generally you shouldn't
it's it's okay to allow maybe in some
cases of course a space advantage in
this case upon on d5 but allowing space
advantage on both wings of the board
that's asking for trouble upon on d5
upon on f5 that's tough
so in the event that I do go forward
with g3 and f4 I think it's important
that black captures they are giving up
their Center but maybe they can make use
of these squares now I do have an
isolated pond so the squares in front of
it can be some type of outpost for
pieces and it's it's still very very
difficult for black hmm you know I'm
just going back and this is what I do a
lot you know when I'm reviewing games
all let me try to express what I just
thought right there before I hit that
rewind button or that back button I
thought to myself well if I know if I
know that black should be capturing here
just so I don't get that f5 advance in I
thought that gee file is going to be
opened up you know after this takes
takes the G files opened up I then
thought to myself well couldn't I have
made a more useful move with my rook
earlier like right here instead of rook
to e1 how about this move here King to
h1 it seems a mysterious for right now
but now this idea of g3 if Bishop here
I'm fine without I'll play rook to g1
and now this idea of f4 and if you're
taking well you're helping out my rook
and if you're not taking the as
mentioned great space advantage with d5
and f5 now one might also question
this point here well am I not able to
play f5 no matter what the difference
here is that after a first capture if
I'm playing a 5 there is this square
that the knight could be jumping into
this is still a favorable position for
me because black is not able to maintain
a piece on the e5 square they have to
recapture with the pawn and now I have a
connected passed pawn and this is still
a very good pawn transformation this is
still good for white but ya didn't quite
turn out like that we didn't get to see
these plans in mind but I certainly
still wanted to share them with you
let's get back to the actual game Bishop
to e3
b3 and Queen there and then b5 they're
saying the best move was b6 here this
right here is the computer line okay it
is going in for g3 Bishop there h6 in
now interesting f3 I guess to play
Knight to f2 that's interesting kick
that Bishop out of there
oh cool may even be the idea of g4 and
night to have two so that's that's
pretty neat to be aware of huh
that gets out of the way trading light
square bishop s' okay and then there's
some ensuing hmm I see some more ways to
improve here subtle moves nothing
nothing great but small improvements
King g2 and still if this have five
advances in I get that night anchored on
e4 clean e2 bishop there now f4 yeah
this is still the computer line and
that's where it ends but you know we
didn't have b6 in there we had b5 and I
don't know if I well from what the graph
is sitting I didn't let it slip there
it's a pawn and a half
1.8 and beyond and it's just growing
from here yeah I should I should have at
least considered this move it's not
working out because of the pin but I
wonder if I would have fallen for that
if pawn takes here Queen here Bishop
back I think I could have very easily
fallen for this tactic now because on
Knight takes there isn't Bishop here
anymore
there is no pin so if that did happen
let's say if the pawn recaptured like
this I would have still played Queen c2
Bishop back and now how to defend here
Bishop d3 or we're actually Bishop to f3
just to stop this forward move Knight g4
pivoting here and now Knight here maybe
g3 Knight back and now Bishop here and
then eventually I control you v this is
important I want to allow this Knight to
make use of that e5 square to sit on the
e5 square for any great length of time
but yeah we didn't quite get there we
had that knight takes and then the
knight was pinned and it was just
downhill from there just looking for
exchanges and being as forceful as
possible here so yeah that's pretty much
all I have to share for this one feel
free as usual to leave any comments in
the comment section below to this one
and as always I hope you got something
out of it that's all for now take care
bye
you